Oh check check
can you hear me I am me Who am I talking
to um Jack Jack Jack Jack Jack
what was that thinking about um Oh
eucalyptus sound like a question doesn't
it when you first hear it you know if
somebody runs up to you say hey eight
eucalyptus
I'll be like why who who said I did
that's what I would maybe eucalyptus oh
no you heard the wrong thing khalipa nah
never heard of him and what else was up
I wanted to tell you guys Oh walnuts are
disgusting can we quit pretending like
they're not you see them sometime on a
salad or you know as an item as a
written item on a menu get you a little
side of this little you know get your
Lowell Oh mannequin of strawberry
ramekin get your little ramekin or
strawberries or get your little ramekin
a walnuts [ __ ] I don't want a walnut
they're disgusting you know what they
taste like they taste like um they taste
like you shouldn't be eating them go go
get a walnut
everybody they have all I mean they got
great PR you know they got great public
you know advertising but they're damn
garbage they're just damn garbage man so
anyway let's get into it man you know
where we are yeah
[Music]
happy Father's Day everyone
little time for me to sell that parking
brake and let myself my wine shine
[Applause]
[Music]
I'll sit and tell you
and that is it that is shine by Bishop
Gunn and I hope everybody had a
wonderful Father's Day you know that
father that's that is wild seeing up you
know I remember the first time when I
was a kid when I saw my dad I just I
remember you know he had on like a dress
shirt I remember in a and a watch or
something you know in a pants and shoes
and and that was him you know and just
pretty nondescript really honestly I
mean you know he was probably 74 years
old or something but you know they had a
guy in my neighborhood this boy's small
Allen and he not mentioned in before he
was a he was not a neighbor but you know
could have been a neighbor if he to live
closer kind of person and his uh and he
was small I mean damn he could barely
he'd play hide-and-seek for a month six
weeks you know he was the only one if we
were playing hide-and-seek you'd see him
you know get a bunch of food and stuff
cuz it was gonna be he gonna be out
there for awhile he's so small he hot in
a bird's nest or something you know
you'd be looking around for everybody
you hear somebody fighting with a bird
in a tree and that would be small up
there just going just just wing the fist
with a damn sparrow or uh you know a
daytime Nightingale because sometimes
you see a nightingale gets law
to net [ __ ] out there during the day
you're like damn this thing it's a damn
pervert but uh but small man he could
hide in his daddy's shoe that's what I
was telling you that's house I mean he
probably weighed I when I first met him
he would probably weighed probably 14
pounds maybe or maybe I bet maybe 14
pounds 2 ounces if he had a damn you
know if he had a couple Charleston shoes
in his pocket but uh you know he was the
kind of boy that could hide in his
daddy's boot just that kind of boy but
anyway happy Father's Day to everybody
belated and if you're a father and and
you have a child I bet it's pretty a bit
of special you know and I bet it's nice
to just to have another chance I think
about sometimes having another chance at
being young and you know and that's
really one of the beauties of life is
that is that second chance you know the
just the way that um you know you get
your own childhood as a child but then
you get one you get to do one right if
you know if you don't get it right here
if you don't if it isn't you know the
things that happen to you you get to
redo them you get that do-over and
that's what a program what a program
that's been designed for us what's going
on man I I'm at home I decided I'm gonna
try doing the podcast back at home not
in the studio just tonight
you know just tonight it's Sunday night
and uh and so yeah just sometimes the
studio like all the just the bells and
whistles of it it doesn't feel the same
it doesn't feel
I don't know I don't know why so I
thought well maybe I'll try it back at
home right where I started just in my
kitchen you know so if you're watching
on the YouTube you're singing that
you're singing just the I mean it is
damn bare-bones in here bare-bones I
mean just like a damn naked skeleton in
here just like a skeleton that just Oh
couldn't even find a loincloth my good
goodness look at that thing just showing
off its occipital is out here put on
some shades you naughty bone man yeah
what's going on let me think about it
man uh we got some calls we got things
to discuss and things not to discuss and
we have you know we just have the world
a summertime it's summertime and that's
one thing it feels like this year
because of the disease it feels like I
don't know it does a birthday count the
summer count the spring count it seems
like I mean next year we better get a
serious do-over you know next year we
better get a damn serious do-over
because nothing for you it's just
feeling like nothing counts kind of hope
you guys can hear me okay
if the audio or video is bad you can
only blame moi and that's French me baby
that moi um but what else is going on
what else is going on out there not to
love me I don't know what I even do this
weekend I feel like oh I had some
breakfast with my buddy and he got the
rancheros and I got the regular you know
bacon egg and uh what else
other where someone's gonna tell you I
don't know just all this I mean we're
just in the damn future I've been
feeling like I've been feeling man we
are in the future this is a rough ER
like how much more future can we get
have you thought of it
how much more future can we get before
you just emailing people to you know to
Istanbul or to Rome I mean that's what's
next really getting emailed who you
email them with how I got emailed with
Delta you know oh I got me a real cheap
email over on spirit emails dude that
would be the worst spirit emails and
that's when they can transport you and
they sting you through you show up do
your luggage doesn't make it you're like
damn they press the button and they put
with duda the human email or whatever
and [ __ ] my arms I think my arms didn't
even come through like holy [ __ ] so now
you got to spend the whole holidays with
your family just you can't even hug
anybody you just got to serve all people
people don't know if you want a hug they
just probably guess you don't because
you don't you know you really have to
have your arms too otherwise nobody ever
know if you want a hug or not they just
think you don't like them you almost
have to get a little like a signal or
something you know like a that means you
need a frickin you need somebody to just
hold you and you know and just hold you
and just and you just kind of pinch them
with your shoulders I guess if you don't
have arms but then I mean you imagine
that they start transport and just
emailing people and look you get
there's different types of ways there's
like if you get emailed in coach it
takes a little while thank you about
nine minutes to get there you just you
know you're just in the stuck in the
power lines or whatever or in the Wi-Fi
maybe your spouse gets lost y'all
supposed to be in Hawaii or something
that you know that bastard gets lost and
it's just suddenly you're single again
you know like damn alright
you know we went with United you know
it's supposed to be unlimited megabytes
and I guess you know Ronnie put on
weight and they just they couldn't
handle it couldn't handle him through
the system and so I guess I'm just I got
all the sunscreen I won't this week what
else is going on
not nothing oh we had sugar Shawn come
on sugar so on the MMA fighter and that
was wild man that guy it's just I mean
you guys know you know a lot of you I'm
fascinated by MMA fighters and even
regular fighters hell I'll you know I'll
bet on two of these bastards in the park
over by me and he's they got some you
know I saw two [ __ ] over there
throwing down for a damn you know half a
pineapple two days ago so it's you know
uh they got you know I I've started to
get more into the sport and I'm watching
old fight and it's just yeah you know
but sugar Shawn man he he's that high
he's that high sucrose smack talker and
it's so funny because you'd ask him
about somebody or interesting cuz you'd
ask him and he would look well how do
you think you'd do in a fight with
so-and-so and he would close his eyes
and think about it any bike I'm out
because it's interesting some people
just talk [ __ ] you know some people
should have a toilet for a chin because
they just sagging not
but Oh sugar Shawn maybe he is he really
visualizes it and every time in his
visualizations he comes out of Victor
that's interesting isn't it because I
guess I just don't have that same
wherewithal you know it in my
visualizations half the time I come I
get the third place
I'll take bronze and Mon dreams that's
crazy so so that was really captivating
man I'm excited for a I'm glad you guys
you know I'm glad those guys let me
interview them and learn about their
space a little bit you know I can feel
come not conflicted sometimes but just
you know it hasn't been my territory but
you know that's been one of the gifts in
knowing Dustin Poirier man is a you know
by him you know being willing to come on
the show and then other peeves you a
little bit of credit with the other
people you know and um and I'm excited
man Dustin's got to fight this weekend
coming up you know I'm real excited
about that man I'm real excited and it's
funny cuz I said man I just when I first
started watching him I wasn't that into
it but now I'm into it now that I know
nobody's gonna die I think I used to
think people died like it was like
Running of the Bulls over there and
diploma spanner if you guys have ever
been know been there but um every year
in diploma they have Running of the
Bulls and basically they take the
baddest bulls in the world man I'm
talking a bunch of damn horse grunts you
feel me I'm talking abunch of Scotty
trip ins bruh and they let those [ __ ]
loose through the city and people have
been drinking wine and talking [ __ ] and
people are wearing t-shirts that say
like you know
go Pistons or something or Celtics in
four you know and then these bad bets
just come through the street and like
7:00 a.m. because I've been there
you know I'm not bragging but I'm you
know I guess I am boasting a little and
then that I mean you're out there and
and uh and they got wine and everybody
people drinking wine out of all kind of
[ __ ] you'll see a dude uh you'll see a
dude with a with a casket or whatever a
wine a flask it you'll see a dude with a
basket of wine a mask it you'll see a
dude wearing a mask he'll take that
[ __ ] off drink right out of it you like
to him
dudes frickin huh it's the Phantom of
the slopper I do because that dudes
getting sloppy as hell off his damn face
piece yeah yeah yeah you see it all you
know and then when everybody's just
liquored to the gills I mean I mean your
buddies just turned into a damn
largemouth bass but you are liquored to
the gills when you've had as much wine
as you can and people drinking out of
everything you'll see a dude he'll he'll
of he'll of uh installed a damn tube
into his um that's a fog as a bra you
know or whatever it's called that you
know that liquid pipe that takes liquid
into your body from your face he'll have
a tube installed into his s of fog as
Brun have that [ __ ] run right back up
to his mouth he's stepping out of
himself like ice just a straw so he'll
drink some ah a little bit of that vino
and then just swallow it and then then
revisit that [ __ ] just he just recycling
that liquor right out of himself
just redoing it you know and you're all
good man you're out there and
everybody's got on white and red and
everybody's got on red and white and and
then you think it's fine you start to
forget even that it's a party cuz this
7:00 a.m.
those Bulls they get up early fur for
work
you know cuz a bull doesn't have a
really a busy day really they got to be
pissed as hell and it's sometimes they
use them for sex but that's it otherwise
they're chillin man eatin corn eating
grass eatin I don't know some look like
they're on damn steroids if you ever
seen a bully like hey I'm dude I got
must own a couple anytime Fitness's you
know because as I do been eatin
Halloween because that little bastard is
jack-o'-lantern Brooke um
[Applause]
was I talking about [ __ ] I don't know I
don't know man uh-oh I hope you're doing
good you know I hope you're doing good
you're doing good you know we got this
we're almost through the disease man and
we got this you know and and and it's
it's only doom and gloom if you know
it's only doom and gloom if you don't
write your own weather report if you let
somebody else write your weather report
then yeah they got control over it but
if I you know also wake up every day and
is write a hundred percent chance of the
best me you know a hundred percent
chance of life a hundred percent chance
of peace you know I should
my own forecast you know I don't I talk
about myself too much I don't even know
what's going on oh oh so then you're out
there in the street you're out there in
the street boy you forget you forget
it's a party
you're starting to check out some cheeks
you know some chick Goss and she got us
or what I don't even at they call them
Italian cheeks brah you know some real
legit euro ladies and they're flirting
and people are starting dancing you know
Oh papa oh you're no papa you're no Papa
no Nino's for me you know and you think
everything's cool you forget bruh cause
you've been drinking and then about a
dozen of the angriest animals you ever
seen come run it through bruh and first
all the chicks disappear all the women
that are they are disappearing like oh
man what happened you know did Larry's
dad come home or something cuz we saw
our way do we all got the party's over
you know did rot you know did Ronnie's
grandfather find out or something that
we're out here in the boathouse because
we're [ __ ] you know what happened did
somebody spray mace or something at the
party because all the chicks start
leaving they're climbing over the fence
is in climbing over they got these big
like twelve by twelves really they
really are they put them all along the
streets the street ways and it's
beautiful streets cobblestone and then
you hear her bottom bottom bottom you're
like damn somebody's trying to move a
piano or something you know because you
forget cuz you've been drinking yeah man
right and then if you see one bull go by
you like that ain't a thing who somebody
better come catch that bastard
then you see eleven more yeah and they
keep ripping through and it's just it's
magical if you never been there go
watching and go see but here's what
happens is at the end they the fighters
there's a swordsman there's a swordsman
a guy out there really really it's
almost like a larper like one of those
guys you see in the park like if they
got a real nerd he's up there in the
park or something you know it's like
some guy who basically the guy that won
the Renaissance Fair in America they
take him to Italy and give him a damn
battalion or something you know a like a
sword man you know that blood peace baby
that sword and that dude pops off with
it he starts fighting the bulls and uh
and oh wait here's up first he has a
carpet and the Bulls come by and he
showed them the carpet and they don't
everytime they don't want to buy it they
just run right through yeah we don't
even even buying that [ __ ] you know and
he only got one carpet it's kind of like
a rerun a little it's like oh you want
to buy this like not a run right by
Queen and we don't want it and he'll
shake that bastard out there again you
know just like he's beating his car mats
off over about a car wash by the DIY car
wash so why not like to use and he's
just you know like he's shaking out the
floor mats of a damn 84 Ford Escort and
uh and then eventually the bull gets so
tired and he swords him out and he
swords him out and they drag it off they
drag the bull off at the end and uh uh I
mean there was some moral to this story
that really was there was a moral to the
story but you know how it is man and you
know how it ain't man I got this muscle
stress in me it will not go away and the
UM the massagers just opened back up and
God I went in there
you know the massagers just opened up
back here in California and I'll tell
you dude I never really you know I've
never been in like body love with
another man or anything but man I've
never been so happy to see this man and
this man is I think he might be Filipino
I think Pinoy you know beautiful one of
the beautiful Pinoy and he my god man I
took my shirt off right when I saw it
was just like a I mean it was it was
like somebody just beat open a damn bag
of magic right in between us because I
it was just many this is man he you know
this man his name is BK BK like bike if
you say bike but if you say it
completely different BK and like a bird
like the hard part of a bird at the
beginning you know that became and he do
it in BK and also here's the crazy thing
they got another guy that works in there
named BK and so it's hard when you call
on the phone if you want to set up an
appointment with one of the gentlemen
cuz they say do you want I'll be like
guys begin and they're like you want be
gay I don't know what they're talking
about
I'm like I want beat day and they say
you won big a big day and it's just and
then we both laugh man it's just I don't
know I love that place
but it's called a Seri foot spa SI RI
foot spa and they got beautiful people
that work in there and just um anyway if
just I've never been so happy to see
another man and just put my body in his
damn hands for an hour for $40 praise
God man thank you guys for being here
today and we're gonna get into some of
this we got some calls that have came in
at always the hotline is nine eight
five six six four nine five zero three I
got to see if we have any ads tonight so
I got a text Nick and have them send me
do that right now
[Music]
what's let's get into it man yeah I just
want to say thank you guys so much for
support in this podcast oh we got the
new gang gang slides are available and
slides are basically sandals you know
Morehouse sandals but you can check them
out at Theo von store.com you can check
those out and let's take a couple calls
here we go gang hey hey what's going on
my man I just wanted to check in with
you make sure everything is really good
with your podcast and everything thank
you brother I appreciate it everything
is going pretty good you know I'm happy
to have you know still have the podcast
right now you know I know a lot of
people haven't been able to work and and
so I think this has been you know I know
that people listen to this as a form of
you know entertainment and so I'm glad
that I've been able to do this and I'm
so grateful for all the calls when so
many calls come back in and so I learned
so much about what's going on with uh
with with you guys so it's pretty
perfect actually
anyhow onward man I have one question
for you do you think that everybody
should start taking their masks off with
this cologne of [ __ ] or do you think
everybody should be more conservative
and leave their masks on and wait to see
what's going on and happen after
everything opens up gang brother and
thank you for their verbal uh inquiry I
you know I say this hmm well you know
what actually this is Nick right here
with the ad and Thank You Nick and now
this is a great time to suggest this
company and this episode is brought to
you by better help better help will
assess your needs and match you with
your own licensed professional therapist
in that nice of them you can start
communicating in in under 24 hours and
better help is a place to get help
look we all I believe that we all need
help and sometimes you meet somebody who
doesn't need any help that person is a
hero but the rest of us the other 99% of
us can use some help every now and then
and you can start communicating in under
24 hours with a helper a mental
professional it's professional
counseling done securely online there's
a broad range of expertise in better
helps network which may not be locally
available some of you live in the woods
some of you live in a dam uh you know a
dugout or something you know sometime
you kick over a you know you'll you
you'll kick over a hub a boat and it's
set on it with the with the open side on
on the ground you and you'll flip it
over and be a dam you know family at 200
air like what in the hell like yeah man
we don't you know we don't know where to
get mental help say well look I know a
place better help is more affordable
than traditional offline counseling and
financial aid is available if you don't
want to go to the therapist in your town
you know II maybe that maybe they're
married to somebody you know you know
maybe the therapist in town is your wife
or your husband better he'll want you to
start living a happier life visit better
help calm slash Theo that's B et te RHEL
p.com slash th e oh and join the over
500,000 people taking charge of their
mental health with the help of an
experienced professional and our special
offer
for our listeners 10% off your first
month at better help.com slash Theo and
let me answer the question now with the
masks I I believe this if you want to
wear a mask
then you shall wear it you can't other
people may not want to wear a mask
that's why you can wear one if you want
to I don't like them people tattletaling
and this and this you know Bridget don't
have a mask on you know excuse me I
don't know if you've noticed or not but
um there's a man of a you know drinking
a little lemon and without a man's gun
well have you ever thought maybe that
man doesn't have a mask on because he's
trying to get some lemonade in his mouth
what do you want you want that guy to
pay for a lemonade and then just splash
it all up against a dam you know that
cloth face piece and he can't even and
just imagine what it tastes like and
wasting money so just don't think about
yourself I think when it comes to
ratting out people they don't have a you
wear a mask that's why we can wear one
if I want to wear a mask I can wear it
some places I feel like I need a mask on
some places I do I do not so I don't
know man I'm sorry to get fired up about
that but uh you know I think it's it's
up to you so that's why you get to wear
one cuz you can't control everybody else
so that's what I think and I think
because a lot of people have decided
they drawn the line kind of in the sand
for themselves you know and it's you
know I don't know if you're ever gonna
be able to get everybody to do the same
thing anymore I don't know if that's the
place we live in
stay
you know me might we you know you might
just not get that and some you know
there's just different types of people
dude I have a buddy out here and he
whenever gets like food delivered and
groceries he gets something he has him
set down in his front yard he goes out
in a hazmat suit okay and a hazmat suit
as you know you know what it looks like
it's like uh you know it's like breaking
bad it's like the guys from Breaking Bad
but they're not they're not even making
drugs or just kind of afraid of
something this man goes out in a hazmat
suit and he and he pressure washes and
cleans off all of his any groceries that
are delivered before he takes him into
his house whoa and look that he can do
that uh if I look if my child and he
ft-ev I think poor children if my child
ever saw me out there pressure washing
and Febreze in a damn box of Triscuits
bro that kids never gonna be the same
that kid is never gonna think I'm a man
after that so you know it just depends
on what you want to do and what you want
your kids to see you doing you know it's
the same I say it always with bike
helmets yes a bike helmet will keep you
safer but do you want your child to see
you ever in a bike helmet that meet your
kids gonna go to therapy oh yeah I
remember my dad coming in the house in
his bicycle helmet you know that's just
you know it's just it's how you want to
live so to each their own that's what I
think I don't think there should be any
big rulings this and that I think to
each their own because you can always
have a mask so you can always prevent
yourself from somebody else's uh you
know uh spit spit them what do they call
it spittle spittle you know because
sometimes your tongue is just spittle it
doesn't even know and they say you can't
see it like your tongues just jerking
off all day just your can your DNA right
out into the air it's unbelievable man
but thank you for calling man and thank
you guys for uh for supporting the
podcast
let's take it here's a call that came in
right here as always the hotline is nine
eight five six six four nine five zero
three and you can call that if uh if
anything's going on you want to talk
about something you heard on the show
you want to recommend something we
talked about you know you have
constructive criticism about something
that's going on or if you're you know if
you're in a tough spot you know hit the
hotline man
onward hey Theo I'm a real son of a
[ __ ] I just want to let you know I
[ __ ] love your show son ha ha ha ok
when there you go right there
so there you go I carefully I said that
there was this whole message of hand oh
I gotta listen to that words how uh well
a lot hey Theo I'm a real son of a [ __ ]
I just wanna let you know I [ __ ] love
your show
there you go man boy dude that makes me
want to take a hit out of my autumn own
wine I mean she wasn't her freakin read
ring
my own wine man makes you want to put a
straw in my stomach in this damn have a
glass of milk the natural way and then
have that second glass right out of my
own body
um another call here we go
hey what's up to you this is uh this is
Mike
got a detective I'm sorry man I missed
set up Mike
what my detective thank you for calling
Mike beautiful over there Tejas on work
detect is more specifically because you
know almost Texas the biggest [ __ ] yeah
Texas is really that's the place is so
big it just it could be a couple places
you could have Texas you could have
Nexus over there by El Paso where it
gets real Mexican you know shout out all
other magic dumbest me amigos me got my
arrows you can oh you could have Mex us
maybe and you could have a Texas you
could have Lexus maybe a certain area
where people just drive Lexus's you know
or fancy Toyotas that's all it is you
know it huh hate to freaking just kill
your buzz but Alexis is just a damn you
know it's just a Toyota and sheeps you
know in fancy sheep's clothing um
homework I've been hearing but you know
Joe Rogan and Brendon Schwab and you
know thinking about moving over here and
I'm recommending and it's a great place
to live you know you you don't want to
get into the smaller towns and [ __ ] you
know because that's one that gets a
little dicey you know I'm saying special
if you got kids you know oh I like dicey
brother you know do plug a vacuum in man
it's sup and just put that sup big
suction cup of my back man that Dyson
that's what I like dicey baby you know I
just to take me that dicey is just God's
casino man
let's see what he rolls baby homework
these parents go [ __ ] crazy over some
sports and baseball and football and
[ __ ] you know there's too many politics
in it even as a young kid that kind of
is a the just of it is moving to a
different place and moving to Texas yeah
honestly man I have been thinking about
it and I've been thinking a lot about it
you know especially recently with the
you know with just the club's being
closed down and I've really been
thinking about um about a move or at
least having another place yeah and a
place that I live at and I'm more based
out of I've been thinking about going to
Nashville to look and I've been thinking
about uh about possibly Texas as well
man I just I've been thinking about it a
lot you know it's interesting during
this time of the disease that everybody
you know you just get a different view
of what's going on kind of you get a
view of your life you get you get a
really an interesting chance of a
reflection that you know that I don't
even know if the generation before us
even got anything like this you know I
think there's a lot of people who've
been doing something for years and now
they're like I don't even know if I like
doing this you know some people started
doing something 20 years ago and now
they're still doing it maybe a certain
job or a you know a pastime and now like
what I don't even you know I was making
shiver roads for people I was doing
unique furnitures and I've [ __ ] I don't
even know if I like it
I just got some saying you know I got a
hot batch of sandpaper for Christmas 20
years ago and so you know and we lived
in the bend of a river so a lot of fancy
driftwood came down and
I got into it and I just never stopped
because it was my job and but now you
get some reflection you're like [ __ ]
I always wanted to do something
different I wanted to do painting or
something you know I wanted to do
photography or you know make homemade
spaghetti or something you know just
different opportunities but but I have
thought a lot about it man let's take a
let's take another call here homework
it's up to you
my name is Deshawn what's up dis on
thank you for calling man and Deshawn is
Spanish for also the Shawn homeward from
Norman Oklahoma called Cory I don't know
how many times now I didn't know that
I'm sorry brother thank you for calling
man thank you hope you like I hope you
call them just ask a few questions and I
I mean I just hope you maybe even
thought about the question you know but
uh yeah man I gotta ask you a question
right now have you thought about doing
any outdoor venues for shows you know
summertime right now people are itching
to get out of the house well people are
itching you know we don't know why
they're itching and that's I mean anyway
people could be itching for anything but
or you know for any reason it could be
asked bestest it could be you know my
buddy he punched all the damn uh drywall
out of his bedroom and so he had exposed
uh what does this [ __ ] call used to make
snowman out of it it was like kind of
pink like uh
I just was talking about it um there was
a system it went in the walls it was
fluffing I think it's called for
temperature fluffing you know I'm
talking about what am I talking about
man it's like temperature fluffing you
know Oh in the walls man anyway it had
something in it had piece of damn you
know glass or something or some kind of
thing something you know fake glass or
whatever
bitchin it was basically just pieces of
damn [ __ ] they would make you itch and
this fluffing or whatever anyway my
buddy would always get pissed and
listening to um he would listen to that
song all the time H come out and
remember that song you got to keep him
separated
he had a CD machine single disc at [ __ ]
and he played that song over and over
again and he was furious at everything
about his family and stuff and he
eventually got into pilled but this
before that you know before pills you
know BP and he beat all the damn walling
out of his walls so all they had was
that fluff in their wall fluffing and
that [ __ ] got to itching so dude we'd
stay over there in Jesus hard as hell to
get a catch a few decent winks when
you're just getting bodied up all night
by this you know this [ __ ] will fall out
like you think it was cotton candy or
something it wasn't it's basically like
somebody just like if the devil made
cotton candy think about that
yeah just like that maybe but if I
thought about doing outdoor venues yes
that's the simple answer and there's
talk right now if people do in Drive in
shows and in shows like that outdoor
areas you know stadium or something
style seating sort of thing but
drive-ins are the ones that I've been
hearing right now that some comedians
are going out to do so once there's more
knowledge about that I'll know more you
know my thing is I don't want somebody
honking the whole time you know what if
somebody there laughs and they're having
a BL AST and they have a stroke
you know because they don't take care of
their body they're not doing fitness or
adult fitness and that [ __ ] strokes out
and they fall on the horn
so now half my set you know the next
three minutes of my set are ruined
because this bastards back there you
know cuz he gots damn you know bad you
know he's got that bad pump on him so
that's the only thing I'm worried about
it just you know people being [ __ ]
and hitting the horn or people stroking
out and physically can't handle their
own being alive because they don't eat
well what else man let's get into a few
more questions here we go
what's up zo hope you're doing well I'm
a big fan thank you and I hope you're or
I know you're going to get a lot of
these kind of questions because it's
kind of a hot topic right now and you're
kind of kind of close to it I just want
to hear your thoughts on on Chris D'Elia
man I'm a big fan of has some big fan of
yours I'm a big fan of a bunch of
comedians like yourself but I don't want
to believe - dude I really don't um you
know it's I feel like that that crying
old man at the the WWE whatever thing is
like it's still real to me damn it you
know that's how I feel so maybe try
helping me feel a little bit better Theo
von I want to thank you for the call
brother I appreciate it and um you know
a lot of calls have come in about this a
lot and and I wanted to wait to speak on
it until I was here at the podcast and
until we were all together you know I
just want to say you know how horrible
this this this was for the girls who
felt like they couldn't say anything you
know how horrible this must have been
for the girls who felt like they didn't
have a voice you know for a period of
time that they couldn't you know speak
up for themselves out of fear or we're
you know I'm not sure what they were
everything they were going through I
don't know but you know I'm happy that
they found a voice - to speak I'm happy
that they found the courage to speak up
I also I wrote some things down that I
want to be that I want to say so I want
to be real clear you know because my
mind it's you know I don't know I'm not
always the most clear you know I
sometimes get real brackish in in my
brain and
and so I just want to be clear man so I
just want to say that I know that there
was a video pulled out of a podcast that
may have given the vibe that I had prior
knowledge of anything predatory that was
going on or occurring I never knew
anything
predatory occurring I had I have never
seen Chris with any underage women ever
I've never heard him I've never heard
him communicating with any underage
women I've never spoken with him about
anything like that ever I've never heard
him speak with anyone about anything
like that you know I would never condone
that type of behavior I would never
laugh about it you know podcast and you
knew how it is we just talked been
talking for years and we give each other
you know a good rough time about stuff
and and Chris and I've always had this
you know to me anyway this is my
perception that we've always had this
you know we give each other a rough time
about things and and his fans are called
babies and you know I know he has a lot
of younger fans and my brain just goes
like a you know it's like a guy without
legs in a you know in a damn avalanche
contest or something you know I would
just I'm just
it just goes sometimes it's a lot of
rambling it's what a lot of podcasting
is but I never had any knowledge or
evidence or idea or reason to suspect
that Chris was ever doing anything that
was that was wrong and I would never
condone anything like that
you know and I hope that Chris gets the
help that he needs and you know and I
always hope that you know always hope
that anybody gets the help that they
need
and um and it's heartbreaking you know
it's heartbreaking because I was also a
fan you know and and that's all I'm
gonna say about that what else
III know it's hard to to talk about
stuff and to share more well let's let's
get through this episode man gang it was
going on deal my name is Derek Mann and
um I came up on the year silver what's
up Derek and congratulations baby you
got that on yo you got that on yo baby
wow that's crazy to do that for a year
on work may 25th
I mean not much fanfare the day came and
went but I didn't even really think
about it or nothin but like yesterday my
girl gave me one of those one of those
like coins you know like when you go to
aim and you hit like a year mark dude
I'm like cracking up yeah just an idea
when you hit the one-year mark even one
of the points that you made and whatnot
but oh yeah they give you a year chip
that chip and they give you a nice when
you when you when you get that on you
baby they give you that nice that
weighty one feels like you could buy
something in the 1800 with like you
could get a damn mule or something with
it or a small you know a baby horse
homework it was out the blue dude and it
was one of the nicest most heartfelt
things someone has ever gotten in and
yeah sorry keep you realized sometimes
though that you think people could care
less
got their own stuff going on but the kid
the most and I really needed it at that
moment dudes [ __ ] I've been having
hard time struggling a little bit with
my sobriety let them stand strong but
just you know no struggle there man I
don't know I appreciate that man thank
you for the call brother and it is isn't
it an interesting man that there's some
reason when you when you're feeling like
nobody cares and you get a message or a
call or a gesture from somebody and it
just surprises you man it just takes you
by a total other direction yeah I mean
those hitting the feelings they hit hard
and the feelings don't they yeah man I
I'm just proud of you man and thanks for
sharing you know I've been struggling
with some of my own kind of uh you know
with some lone sobriety stuff and and uh
I mean you just sharing that with me you
sharing how somebody else made you feel
important you know how your girl just
surprised you with that chip you know
with that coin with that one year saying
hey you know I see you you know I see
you taking care of yourself and and I'm
proud of you you know I see you
it's powerful man it's powerful when
somebody except when somebody does that
for you and yeah man I'm proud of you
man I'm proud of you and I know you're
proud of you too that's what makes me I
think feel even you know that makes me
feel some type of way right now because
you know I know that you're proud of you
and I know also I could tell that you
feel loved by the person that did that
for you that's somebody that loves you
man you know and people could tweet
about love and say this and now and we
could show images in this and that and
we could post all the [ __ ] we want but
that that's God's Instagram bro you know
that's when some would that wasn't that
somebody can make you have a feeling
like that that's powerful man and look
your girl doing that for you man made me
feel like this made me feel something
you know so yeah man I'm just so proud
I'm just proud of you bro you know I'm
proud of you and um anyway I don't know
what else to say madness yeah it's been
a long week bro and but thank you for
sharing man thank you for being brave
enough to share that too you know
sometimes if somebody does something
nice for us and we put it away and we
you know we want to talk about other
stuff or we want to do different things
it's not that doesn't have as much of a
heart in it but you didn't make that
choice maybe you chose to share that
experience with us and thank you gagging
brother all right let's get a call here
Henry
Henry up there in Battle Creek and asked
than a day I'm funeral home one time and
uh up and um [ __ ] I don't know where it
was homeward brother homeward I just
have some questions about you know I'm
high schooler messing around some
surfaces and okay so your high school
and are you messing in with some
substances okay
homework brother would you say it just
be better for me no long I just you so
right now then uh because I know I do
have a pretty addictive mentality and uh
you know and that's like waiter down the
wrong one
she's off walk around with but um yeah
just wanna know your thoughts about it's
just better to get sober young or ride
it out and really maybe like it's a
bigger lesson to learn I don't even know
peace n love you be good yourself thanks
man I appreciate that that's nice you to
say man you know you I can tell you're a
nice person you know I could tell that
you care about yourself you know and
just nicely to say that at the end there
remember when it used to be best by all
the time middle of the night remember
best by every midnight best buy
get it get this you know it's damn uh
you know uh it'd be like oh you got to
get this man the book of Eli's on or you
know blu-ray or something Pat man on
blu-ray anyway sorry man I obviously I
got some resentments against Best Buy
video pre or something Best Buy
basically which is just China basically
big warehouses full of China but let me
let me let me get
I'm sorry I made that about me there um
you know it's a good question man and
only you can answer it for yourself you
know about get about trying to be sober
getting sober or getting into that world
you know recovery so many people
struggle with things and you know
sometimes I think it's our test overall
as a species can we solve these things
that are broken in us no matter how many
centuries and decades it takes and
generations can we can we solve it can
we solve what they are and alcoholism is
a big one because for a lot of people
it's not even about drugs or alcohol
it's about the way they feel you know
has nothing to do they have people that
have never drank or done a drug who are
alcoholics who are in recovery so if
that just to let you know that it's it's
it's it's a thing going on in your brain
you know or in your spirit but man it's
up you know it's your call yeah I know
what you're saying should I wait um is
there some lesson I'm a learn by you
know being out there and partying and
and I don't know you know some people be
like yeah the answer is just tell them
to get sober yes I could just tell you
that but I don't know if you're an
alcoholic you know I don't know you can
only answer for yourself you know
there's times where I still think I'm
not but but that could be my call as I'm
telling me that um but I don't think it
would hurt you now here's something I
can recommend man I think you maybe go
to a couple meetings you know go to some
different men's stag meetings there's
just men only
so people ain't gazing around in there
you know gazing over there that a you
know some you know something they got a
beautiful lady over there with some two
tots or something
you know you want to focus on what on
the nature at hand so I'd recommend
there you go that's that that's
something I can recommend try a couple
meetings see how you feel
there's even young meetings there's you
there's meanings for more useful so if
you're a youthful man if you got
Youngblood and your body and young bones
and tissue then you could do that but I
do know I do know this man that there is
a solution in those rooms there's a
solution to to a lot there's a solution
to a lot and if that program doesn't get
you there you might just find it your
way to a different there's other
programs there's all types of self-help
but I I'm just I'm glad you're you that
you're calling and singing and you're
just even curious up that you're aware
enough of yourself to say hey shut up we
know what's going on what what thing
what do I do and so I would give it I
would peep it out man you know because
you can always not go but you know but
that you know but it's when I hear
stories like Derrick that call before
you and uh and may you could just tell
that another part of his spirit is
getting it's coming alive you know
and that's something you just you can't
do by yourself that we need others we
need help and all help is a lot of times
is just others it's just a fancy word
for it but uh anyway man a lot of people
also called in about about Chris and
about everything that happened that's
happened with him and uh
and and just I just wanted to say thank
you for the calls and that were
expressing thoughts for me that were
being supportive and and just just how
many just you know just a lot of people
that love him you know very you know an
entertaining man it was just just a lot
of nice stuff and uh anyway let's take
one more call right here that came in
and this is egregious but I'll play it
stop there Birdman from Birmingham
Alabama
what's up bird down here in Bham baby
huh bird down that bro and if I see you
fist fighting up in that nest with small
Allen dog I'm gonna know what's up he
trying to blow up his hiding spot dude
we've been looking for him for three
weeks beat listen man is just calling to
say I love you bro and I'm really
grateful for what you do man and I just
want you to know that there's in the
same way I feel like you're you spent a
lot of time thinking about other people
I just want you to know there's other
people that are thinking about you too
praying about you meditating for you you
know all that good [ __ ] and I don't know
I don't know if you hear this enough but
I just love you keep your head up and
you keep fighting that good fighter
during the hell of a good job bro and
yeah man also I came out and saw you
over in Europe and actually it was
hilarious being from the south and
watching you do some comedy and other
country dude all right man you're on my
mind this morning I was grabbing a good
day bro love you too Gang Gang love you
too bro love you too man thanks bird man
thank you bro that's nice you to say man
oh you know we all we all need to hear
that people care about us you know we
all need to hear it you know what
especially I think at a time like this
where you know there's a lot of
uncertainty out there there's a lot of
like structural uncertainty in our
country and
and even in our species I think you know
are we as a species are we right are we
doing can we do this but thank you burn
- that's really nice of you man I
appreciate you sharing that bro hit me
in him damn valves baby hit me in them
blood valves dog in that first and
second gear bro and that frickin uh and
that ticker in that transmission baby
what's a good song we can go out with
tonight
Stevie starlight has a new album and I'm
gonna try to get some tunes from them I
can play for next week but yeah uh you
know I don't know man I just everybody
we got this man we can do this you know
a lot of phone calls came in - about
people on Greyhound buses and things
that happen - um dude and uh man some
realist and I'm gonna play on next week
we'll get into it next week but take
care of yourselves you know and we got
this and we can do this and I'm talking
to you and I'm talking to me and just
thank you man thank you so much for you
know a lot of calls this week I think a
lot of people knew that you know a lot
of people in the comedy community are
really heartbroken and I know a lot of
you guys are too right now and uh you
know we just we have to just you know
give our love and our support to
everybody everyone you know to everyone
that struggled with the the scenario and
things that have going on and you know
and we you know we move forward
you know we all move forward and we all
get better so I don't know what I'm
talking about man but that's why I got
you guys because y'all do bro
let's do a little bit of making it you
knew it was gonna be making it man
but this is a bishop gun and uh y'all be
good year sales man you deserve it baby
gay
I've seen home is about a hundred days I
can almost hear mama please for my
restless soul and now he made $1 night
spell but where it's going ain't kill me
and I still get wet I'm bound go
Oh
bacon wrong slam right
[Music]
bacon beer time
most all of my friends slip right
through my hands
[Music]
if their spiral wasn't our glance up
sailing I'm about an hour
[Music]
but how
I'll make a move
feel right
[Music]
but
[Applause]
[Music]
I hate seen old men palpable to date I
can almost hear mama cream from our
recipes
[Music]
[Laughter]
and that is uh that's making it and
that's making it right there about
Bishop gun and you can check them out
and uh yeah I think we've said enough
man
I think we've said enough